Well, for a finite state machine and a regular expression to have the same language,
they have to have exactly the same set of strings that they accept.
Let's go try some of those out.
In this particular regular expression, a is in the accepted set of strings.
I need an a, but I could have zero b's and zero c's.
However, this finite state machine does not allow us to accept on a single a.
There's a string in here that's not up there, so this is not part of the answer.
How about this one?
Up here we can see that the string a b nothing is in the language of this finite state machine,
but it's not in the language of this regular expression.
This regular expression requires at least one c. There are no c's up here.
This is also a bad call. Let's take a look at the last one in a bit of a leading ordering choice.
This regular expression uses disjunction, and one possible choice here is
a followed by nothing, followed by nothing, so a is in the language of this regular expression,
but we've already seen that a is not accepted by this finite state machine,
so this one is not quite correction. However, this one is.
Now, this takes a little bit of reasoning. We can certainly start with an a.
Then we have at least one b and possibly more.
This looks a lot like a b +.
Over here, we don't have the a. We just have a b followed by possibly more b's.
So this is a lot like b+.
I've got two branches--on that's ab+ and one that's just b+.
That's an optional a followed by b+.
After that point we have as many c's as we want, but possibly zero.
That's c*, so yeah. This matches number 3.